You
So
Good boy.
Good girl.
You
What did I do to deserve a moment like you?
Exist.
That's what you do.
That's what all of you did.
You exist.
And I'm so happy to have all of you here.
Thank you.
Thank you for being here.
Yes, baby.
It's okay to fall asleep.
If you're sleepy, I want to sleep.
Give in.
Give in while asleep.
Mommy would love to.
I would love to do bedtime stories.
We will save death.
For another time.
Right now, it's relaxation time.
Relax.
But I see some of you are thirsty.
Do you want me to pour you a cup of milk?
Here, may pour you some milk.
Here.
Let me know.
It's in your sleeping cup.
The cup is for the big boys and the big girls.
That's right.
I want more milk.
I will pour you another cup of milk.
Here.
Mommy can be so clumsy sometimes.
There seems to be a milk everywhere.
Mommy does have a towel while I clean it up.
Right now.
Here.
It's okay.
It's okay, baby.
Don't worry.
No matter the mess,
Mommy will be here
to clean it up.
So,
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Mommy is here.
It's a bad time.
We have to wash you up.
Mommy is here.
Look at all the bubbles.
Dry you.
Look at you all nice and dry.
Let's brush that hair.
Make up.
Don't you look pretty.
Don't you look pretty for mommy.
All dry.
I'm looking all my sink clean.
You smell very good.
So good.
That's a good boy.
That's a very good girl.
It's time for bed.
Are you ready for bed?
It's time to get some sleep.
So let's get ready to get some sleep.
Okay?
Mmm.
He's dry.
Get into bed.
I'll talk you out.
You're so good for me.
I'm so very good.
Mmm.
That's right.
Here.
Good.
Are you nice and comfy?
With your favorite blanket?
Mmm.
That's good.
Easy.
All right.
It's time to sleep.
So let me.
You want to.
Make your story.
Okay?
I want to hear a story.
I can tell you a little story about the past.
Now the earth came to me.
And do you want to hear that story?
Mmm.
That's good.
Stay nice and comfy and listen closely.
Once upon a time, when the earth first came to be,
it was empty and flat,
no trees, no mountains,
no light inside.
There was nothing.
And then the silence was broken.
From the earth's cross,
pros, me,
and my family,
my first family.
We had a measurable power within ourselves
and formed beauty and everything on this earth.
And the mountains,
the ground,
the trees,
and the grass.
But I felt
that there was something missing.
Something needed to be there to enjoy the scenery,
the beautiful mountains,
rivers and such.
So I added the fish or the waters.
The shapes.
The cows.
The owls.
And the cats.
So many animals.
And with that,
I created a circle of life.
From there,
seemed something more
than what was missing.
Something there.
Something I already hold so close to being already.
Animals are easy to understand,
but what if there was a being
that more clear control
on their own decisions
and might control
and could continue to grow?
I added you,
my little layman,
precious babies.
Oh, how I cared for you,
the care of you,
thought of you,
clothed you.
I taught you the ways of living.
And from there,
you worshipped me.
You worshipped me, the family.
And all time came
and passed.
My family wanted to
create life themselves.
So they left.
But I just couldn't leave you all behind.
I cared for you all very dearly.
So I left some of my powers
at my divinity with my family.
And I decided to stay
and live amongst you.
And join you.
I loved and still do.
Care for you.
I wanted to spend time with you
and still help you
with everything,
full.
Unfortunately,
time waits for no one.
And with the power of the gods gone,
rose the desire
for power amongst the humans.
And they fought.
They fought.
And fought.
So many precious lives are lost.
None of us.
This is fine.
As time continued to go on,
I felt rather lonely, forgotten.
But I felt this burning desire
and this need
to create a family of my own.
So,
and now I'm here
to gain your heart,
to create a family
of love and care for you.
And I thank you,
all of you,
for being here with me.
It has been a bumpy road,
a long bumpy road.
And I appreciate
every last one of you,
my precious babies.
Thank you, little bleeding hearts.
Thank you.
Love will never stop loving you.
Yes, that means you too.
Thus, in most of the time,
let me must take the leave
and you continue to rest.
You can either keep your eyes closed
and stay asleep
or open them.
Hanging out with me
as we began
to prepare ourselves
for the days to come.
As time will continue to roll
and I will be with you
there at all.
Every second, every minute,
every hour.
You sweet babies.
Yes.
I promise
I'll always be close by
in your heart,
in your prayers
because I am your goddess.
Rock and do away.
You must write.
Help.
I was prepared.
This is me.
Write.
Do you want me
to just end?
I'm afraid to read someone
because what if it wigs everyone?
I should hurry.
Read Shibu.
Shibu is still online
doing an overcock
a collab
with Norikon Taichung.
Do you want to hug? Show.
There you go.
One blind kiss.
You're being so good.
Well deserved.
Hi. It's time for bed.
If you guys can,
I would rather do it like this.
We don't disturb the others.
I'm going to post the link instead.
Okay.
If you guys haven't already done so,
please like and subscribe
and leave a comment in the comment section.
And say,
here's your question today.
Did you enjoy the ASMR today?
And if so, what was your favorite part?
Good night, my sweet ones.
And thank you so much, the Terminator
or the $5 tippy.
Thank you.
I'll wear it.
Once I post the link,
everyone go in.
Click the link
and dance to a raid on official raid
as to not wake the sleepers.
Also please remember,
also follow me on Twitter, please.
Follow me on Twitter for silly posts
and buy my merch in the description below,
along with the Patreon
or more exclusive ASMRs and audios.
Thank you so much all for the $5 tippy.
Never take care of us today, mama.
You're very welcome.
Good night, my babies.
Have a sweet, sweet dream.
And dream of me
cuddling you,
holding you tight.
Mommy loves you.
Don't forget.
Good night.
Bye-bye.
I'll see you tomorrow.